John: Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday.
Some of my Youtube friends are visiting the
set today including none other than Tyler
Oakley!
Tyler: Hi!
This is actually really pretty.
I mean, I'm talking about myself.
John: Yeah.
Tyler: You look great too!
John: Thanks buddy.
Uh, it's question Tuesday the day that I answer
real questions from real nerdfighters except
today I'm gonna ask the questions and Tyler
is going to answer them.
Question 1: Zombies or unicorns?
Tyler: Zombies.
John: What's your favorite pizza topping?
Tyler: Oh, I love a ham and pineapple.
John: Who is your favorite Beatle?
The Beatles's were a band.
Tyler: You know, I don't think I have one.
Don't people say Ringo and then people are
like "Ringo?", so I think I'm going to go
with Ringo.
John: Who is your third favorite member of
One Direction?
Tyler: Hmm, oh, hmm.
That's harder than the Beatles's one!
Zayn!
John: Two more questions.
Tigers or lions?
Tyler: Oh, a tiger.
John: What is the meaning of life?
Tyler: Ummm...oh, love.
Hannah: Hi, I'm Hannah Hart!
John: Hi, Hannah Hart.
What is your favorite movie of all time?
Hannah: Uhh....Paper Towns.
Coming soon?
John: Cats or dogs?
Hannah: Cats.
Slash dogs.
My favorite type of dog, is a dog that thinks
it's a cat and doesn't get so rambunctious.
John: What's your favorite pizza topping?
Hannah: I prefer cats.
*laughing*
John: What's your biggest phobia?
Hannah: Not knowing what to say in response
to a question.
John: What do you want to be when you grow
up?
Hannah: Uhh, a cat.
*laughs*
John: Lastly, what animal do you prefer: wolf
or lion?
Hannah: Definitely wolf.
100%.
John: Gah!
That's a dog!
Hannah: I know....uhhhh....yeah...well I ain't
lion, I do love wolves.
Ingrid: Hello, I'm Ingrid Nilsen.
John: Zebras or lions?
Ingrid: Zebras.
John: Zombies or unicorns?
Ingrid: Unicorns.
John: What is your favorite movie?
Ingrid: Uh....Paper Towns?
John: Pick a movie you haven't seen.
That's smart.
Nobody's seen it.
So nobody knows if it's good yet.
What's your biggest phobia?
Ingrid: Spiders.
John: What do you want to be when you grow
up?
Ingrid: An adult.
Amanda: Hi, I'm Amanda Steele.
My channel is makeupbymandy24.
John: First, what's the meaning of life?
Amanda: Pizza.
John: Zombies or unicorns?
Amanda: Zombies.
John: Nice, good choice.
Favorite flavor of pizza?
Why do I keep calling them flavors when they're
toppings?
Amanda: Flavors, yeah.
Pepperoni.
John: Have you ever seen a ghost?
Amanda: No.
John: Are you left handed?
Rosianna: Hi, I'm Rosianna Rojas.
John: Uhh, my friend and assistant.
Rosianna: Yes, I'm your friend and your assistant.
I also have a video blog.
John: Oh, you're a video blogger?
Rosianna: Yeah.
John: Cats or dogs?
Rosianna: Cats.
John: *exhale* Wolves or lions?
Rosianna: Lions.
John: *exhale* Zombies or unicorns?
Rosianna: Zombies.
John: Finally!
God, I felt like our friendship was being
challenged.
Rosianna: It was dying.
It was slowly dying.
John: What do you want to be when you grow
up?
Rosianna: This.
John: Who's your favorite Beatle?
Rosianna: Maybe Ringo.
John: That's funny that you say that, because
Tyler also picked Ringo.
But only because he couldn't think of the
name of any other Beatle.
And lastly, I know that you're very British
and that you guys don't have cars there.
But have you ever been on a road trip?
Rosianna: Yes.
When I was in California, we drove up from
LA all the way up to San Francisco.
John: Oh yeah, that's not a road trip.
Rosianna: That's a casual, casual outing?
John: Yeah.
I mean that's a commute for a lot of people.
Troye: Hi, I'm Troye Sivan.
John: What's your favorite movie?
Troye: Uh, Moulin Rouge.
John: Ugh, that's a great movie.
Favorite pizza topping?
Troye: Pineapple.
John: What's your all time favorite city?
Troye: Capetown
John: What's the meaning of life?
Troye: Be happy and do good.
Jenn: Hey guys, its Jenn, also known as jennxpenn.
John: Cats or dogs?
Jenn: Oh, this is so tough for me.
I think I'm more of a dog person honestly.
John: That's good.
That's was good decision.
What's your biggest phobia?
Jenn: Spiders, which is a classic answer but-
John: Wow, that was also Ingrid's answer.
Jenn: Really?
John: Yeah.
Jenn: I'm terrified.
John: Mine is abandonment.
Jenn: Abandonment?
John: *laughs* Yeah
Jenn: Really?
John: No, one time I was dating a girl and
she was like "what's your biggest fear" and
I was like "abandonment" and then I said what's
your biggest fear and she said geese and I
was like "oh I see that I have approached
this question incorrectly.
I've made a terrible miscalculation!"
Lastly, what is the meaning of life?
Jenn: Find something that you're passionate
about and do it all the time and love doing
it.
John: Hank, thanks to all of my Youtube friends
for coming to hang out at the Paper Towns
set today.
I will see you on Friday!